d'un côté la famille bouillasse de
l'autre grégory trèfle étudiants en m2
leurs différences charlotte va entrer en
première année d'études supérieures à 3
i/s grégory va faire lui un nouveau
master 2 spécialités finance tous les
deux recherchent un logement pour
l'année prochaine avec plus ou moins de
difficulté un logement nous ayant été
réservées sur une nouvelle résidence on
a profité de ce forum pour venir visiter
la future
location notre demande peine papier il
faut être présent il faut remplir des
critères
voilà faut visiter parfois il faut
regarder la logistique qui a plein de
choses à regarder
donc c'est je trouve que c'est la plus
compliquée pour faciliter la recherche
de logement étudiant saint quentin en
yvelines à développer sa plateforme look
avis objectif mettre en relation les
propriétaires avec les étudiants en
recherche de logement
là par exemple nous avons une
proposition de logement une chambre chez
l'habitant donc là vous avez le
descriptif la surface la disponibilité
et dates de disponibilités et ainsi que
le montant du loyer différents acteurs
publics et privés interviennent sur le
marché du logement étudiant sur le site
de libé est ce qu le crous propose près
de 400 place l'arpège plus de 450
les réservations peuvent se faire durant
tout l'été jusqu'à la rentrée en
septembre